what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Invincible Iron Man and
fall of X and the ending of this I feel
like it's going to blow your all's Minds
it's crazy especially if you're
knowledgeable about the X-Men but what
this does is this picks up with James
RADS in prison now this is one of the
things that we haven't really talked
about too much in the Iron Man Comics
but the long and short of this is that
for those of you guys who are catching
up basically you had a guy named fa long
who ended up taking over Stark
Industries and he ended up using Stark
Tech to build these gigantic 50ft tall
Iron Man suits effectively Sentinels
that could help orcus in tracking down
the X-Men in the entirety of the fall of
X event right finding different mutants
killing them or imprisoning them the
funny thing here is that during the
early days when this happened Tony Stark
and James rhs went on a mission to find
out how far along philong was in
building up these Stark Tech Sentinels
in the process James Rose is basically
busted and arrested now fa long has
played a kind of game using James rhods
as a sort of Pawn against Tony Stark in
the sense that he's always trying to
take these pot shots sometimes to
demonstrate he can kill James rhods
anytime he wants to other times to
actually take out James rhods
legitimately and this is one of those
times when he tries to do it now the
crazy thing here is that basically James
rhods gets a phone call in jail and when
that happens it's basically Tony Stark
who's supposed to be calling him the
funny thing is that during that time
Tony Stark is handed a phone and saying
he's got a phone call so somebody's
basically connected the two and tricked
each one into believing that the other
called them now Tony Stark figures out
pretty fast that it's F long right he's
the one that's basically doing that and
then James rhods gets into a kind of
fight out in the prison yard now one of
the things to also know is it's not
really Tony Stark's fault that James
rhods got arrested it kind of was but it
wasn't it was more of the circumstance
there have been times in the past in
Marvel when like Tony Stark just makes
James rhods the sacrificial lamb and
just like gets him arrested right Tony
Stark is a terrible friend to James
roads if we're being honest but once he
realizes that fa long is kind of doing
this as a game it's really just to kind
of have Tony Stark on the phone
listening to James rhods getting beaten
to death inside of a prison and so
immediately Tony Stark goes to attack fa
long only for Wilson Fisk the Kingpin to
get in his way right to literally show
up and just say a word Mr Stark and when
Tony tells him to leave he says the
arrangements you commissioned from were
implemented in the palansky unit several
days ago only for us to end up finding
out James rhs has help and it comes in
the form of Sandman dude Sandman was
sent into that prison to protect James
rhods this is how you use a Villain Like
Sandman to be honest right this is how
you use Flynn it's awesome to see this
happen right then you end up having
Arthur Parks who shows up the Living
Laser both of these guys intentionally
got themselves around arrested and sent
to this prison on behalf of the request
of Wilson Fisk so they could basically
protect James Rose Now understand here
these guys are not doing it because like
they're altruistic right like it's the
right thing to do James Rose is a
superhero on any normal circumstance
they'd be happy to see this guy get
killed but as we know with Wilson Fisk
while he is traditionally a villain of
Daredevil and was originally a villain
of Spider-Man in more recent years he'
basically worked his way onto the X-Men
team by marrying Ty Mary who is a mutant
and is now part of the hellfire club
right a kind of inner circle that's
working against orcus and those groups
out there trying to destroy the mutant
population and so Wilson Fisk getting a
hold of these guys they did it because
they were likely promised something at
some future point in time either that or
most likely it was money of course
they'll end up being broken out or
something along those lines and they'll
be back to their normal lives but it was
most likely cash right Cold Hard Cash
that's really what it was if I'm being a
betting man but of course of course F
Long's given the news about the fact
that James Road survived the whole thing
and of course he's pissed off now the
cool thing that goes on here is we jump
back to the conclusion of the last video
that we covered which was basically
Hazel now Hazel is Emma Frost of the
X-Men masquerading as just a regular
person honestly she's got the whole like
super hot librarian Vibe going on right
like so that's really cool but in
essence she is kind of hiding in plain
sight she wears a ring that's kind of an
inhibitor ring so basically it prevents
anybody from being able to detect her
mutant power and her being able to use
her mutant power at all but once she
realizes Phong is there phong's part of
orcus and orcus is targeting the mutant
population even if destroying Phong
isn't necessarily going to bring an end
to everybody hunting for mutants across
the world at the very least it is an
anti-mutant guy that she can kill on the
spot and take a lot of her frustration
out on so as we saw in the previous
video Tony Stark leads your in to a room
in order to talk to her she knees him in
the balls he falls down on his knees
only for f long to walk in and then they
immediately improvise he
proposes he just like makes it look like
a proposal because honestly it's the
most logical thing to do he's got a ring
in his hand he's on one knee she's
standing up might as well make it look
good and so probably for the first and
only time in Tony Stark's entire life he
gets like the one chick he's been down
bad for Emma Frost and let's be honest
with ourselves there's not a straight
guy in the entirety of Marvel Comics who
wouldn't give virtually anything to get
a night with Emma Frost you know what I
mean like it's just she's like that in
Marvel but the thing about this is that
there's a kind of back and forth here
right with Fong it's not overly
important but it does kind of feed into
the game the two of them are playing one
of the things to know is that they could
just have like a knockdown drag out
fight that could happen but the problem
is f long's the CEO of Stark industry so
if he's seen out in the street getting
into a fight obviously it would lead
people to question the leadership of
Stark Industries that would lead to a
drop in Stark industry's value and of
course he'd probably be outed as the CEO
by the board of directors Tony Stark
can't necessarily do that because he's
flat broke so who's going to defend him
right I mean that guy's going to end up
in jail and there'll be nobody out there
who is a non-mutant trying to help the
mutant population outside of The Uncanny
Avengers right Captain America's
Avengers team so what ends up happening
is with this kind of back and forth one
of the things that a lot of people who
are unfamiliar with Tony Stark don't
know he is at his absolute most
dangerous when he's backed into a corner
Tony Stark whenever you're facing off
against Tony Stark in any kind of
situation you want to be facing off
against him when he believes he has like
50 potential ways to win right that's
the Tony Stark you want to fight against
because that's the one who's Reckless
that's the one who kind of Devil May
care and might get carried away with
himself and potentially offer you an
opening the Tony Stark who feels like he
has only one way to win that's the guy
who stops joking that's the guy who
stops playing even though he's here
drinking martinis it's all a show right
like this is him just acting it's just
him pretending right that Tony Stark who
feels like he only has one option will
be laser focused on that one way to take
you out and how foolish would you have
to be to piss off the second smartest
man in the world so badly that you
become his just pure unadulterated only
focus that destroying you is the only
thing he cares about it's probably the
dumbest thing that a person could do and
Fay long doesn't realize how badly he's
screwed up because everything that you
see happening right now is all going
according to plan for Tony Stark it's
exactly it's going exactly the way that
he expected it to and so where people
are asking the question like wow Tony
Stark's getting married that's kind of
weird right the billionaire superhero
Playboy who's not really a billionaire
anymore and he's basically flat broke
but hey you know that kind of thing who
ever thought he would have settled down
him and Emma Frost basically take off to
Vegas in order to get hitched now in
this moment right you have fa long who
asks Tony Stark can I come to the
wedding his response is no but the
reason why he says that is because he
knows Fe long will take that rejection
as a challenge and he'll show up anyway
and he'll be the only one who does so
the two of them take off to Vegas right
in order to get hitched because that's
just kind of what you do and then Tony
Stark puts on his nil armor now the nil
armor of ton Stark is some really really
cool Stark Tech it's not like the Uber
suit he's working on and the end of this
will tell us exactly what's going to be
in that suit and it's going to blow your
mind when we get to that point but the
nil armor is basically a kind of like
Espionage suit right it's the suit he
puts on when he wants to sneak in
somewhere it's not really as powerful as
a lot of the other suits are but it gets
the job done the reason why this matters
is because he goes to the base of
operations for Zeke stain the son of
obadia stain basically the former
villain of Iron Man before his death and
his son took over the Empire Zeke
stain's not important here you're not
going to see him at all in this story
but he is incredibly capable it's one of
the things to know among the different
villains that Tony Stark has you have
Ezekiel stain you've got Justin Hammer
right you have people out there who were
very very capable and always gunning for
Stark Tech and always trying to find a
way to work against him such as it is
he's able to basically steal a whole
bunch of Technology from Ezekiel which
be used to effectively build up a new
Iron Man suit gets a hold of Captain
America and then has him send a member
of The Uncanny Avengers to pick up all
this stuff which turns out to be
Deadpool and in the most Deadpool
response ever this is the only time he
shows up right I love it when Deadpool
has like these tiny cameos where he's
wearing like a hat and he's got a
mustache over his mask because you know
Deadpool comics but I love this this
little Cameo here because he's like okay
um I'll get whatever this is back to the
Morlock Tunnels for you because that's
kind of where they meet in secret but
maybe I could stay for your big day
right I was married once and and Iron
Man's just like leave Deadpool and he's
like okay goodbye because the reality
here is once Deadpool starts talking
that dude's not going to shut the hell
up man like he doesn't know how to be
quiet right he'll just talk your ear off
forever and I love
it and so in the following day once Tony
Stark returns he shows up to like this
little chapel of love right gamble of
love and him and Emma Frost basically
are in the process of getting hitched
only for fa long to bust in right to
just kind of Crash the thing and be like
I couldn't say no boom trap set trap
activated at that point Emma Frost takes
off her ring uses her telepathy takes
over the minds of Tony Stark the priest
and Fa long now she knows right off the
bat as does Tony Stark this guy's going
to have psychic blocks in place and
that's an important thing to understand
for non-comic book readers telepathy is
so well known to the general public 99%
of people don't care but for those who
run like companies or like political
officials especially high-ranking
officials so like different dictators
across the world the president of the
United States certain members of
Congress who are privy to like
exceedingly classified and sensitive
information these people will have
mental blocks designed to help resist
telepathy it doesn't completely and
totally shut it down but it does allow
them to offer some measure of resistance
and so in this instance when they enter
into the mind of f long that as we had
seen in a previous Iron Man comic fa
long once he took over Stark Industries
had gotten his hands on this kind of
video message that was recorded by
Howard Stark for Tony but as soon as Fe
Long watched it he torched it so Tony
Stark could never see it this is a
chance for him to see it and what we get
here and this is one of the this is one
of the coolest things because we
speculated about this that it looked
like he was going to the farshore and he
kind of is Howard Stark talks about how
he had basically discovered a kind of
metal right he says I don't have the
discovery in my hand yet because my
prize lies Beyond it's a metal outside
our periodic table that should not exist
because it's outside of our universe if
I'm successful this metal could be more
significant to humanity than iron was to
our ancestors so he says a kind of
goodbye to Tony Stark and tells him I'm
sorry that my work kept me away from you
but you were always my greatest
achievement I.E basically the message
that we saw in like Iron Man 2 right
that's essentially what this is but once
the mental blocks of Phong kick in
keeping in mind all of this is happening
in phong's mind right now the mental
projection of fa long attacks uh Tony
Stark and then Emma Frost steps in and
kind of shuts his mind down but then she
starts asking a question right why does
this guy hate mutants so much right it's
one thing when he was talking about the
idea that like the mutant population
kind of screwed up his attempt to try to
terraform Mars when mutants claimed the
planet for themselves before he could
but that's not enough of a reason to
want to eradicate everybody in existence
right like the person at the grocery
store taking the last bag of Pop-Tarts
isn't really enough for you to like kill
them and their family and friends and
anybody that they ever met right it's
just not really enough to initiate that
kind of Vendetta so what she does is she
starts probing his mind and this is the
answer that a lot of you guys have been
asking about with regards to fa long and
so what she finds out here is that fa
long was born to mutant parents but he
himself did not have any powers and so
what they realize is that his parents
loved him for who he was he resented
them for what he wasn't he wanted Powers
he wanted abilities this whole thing is
literally just an ego trip it's a guy
who just feels inferior to the people
around him and trying to drag down those
individuals who are superior to him to
his level so he can feel more cap
capable right like instead of being
better he wants other people to be as
bad as he is or at least as low as he
sees himself and so it's a very simple
motivation but I love that Jerry Dugan
did this because this is what Chris
Claremont would have done back in like
the 70s and 80s it's exactly what he
would have done not some grand scheme
for world domination or anything like
that it's just the guy feels inep in the
face of a mutant population that
challenges his very existence now in
this moment Frost almost considers using
her telepathy to force this guy into
telling the truth but what she realizes
is that if she were to do that and if
another telepath that works for orcus
were to come along and scan his mind
they would realize a different telepath
had been here they wouldn't know it was
Emma Frost but they would know that a
telepath had been inside his head and
then at that point it's very easy for
him to say well I didn't actually mean
it I was forced to say it by a telepath
because you know those mutants they
can't be trusted and the whole of the
human population sides with him and it
was all for nothing and if anything it
makes things worse for the mutant
population right so the smart move by
Emma Frost is to just kind of let things
lie and then essentially walk away now
following that with the whole like fake
mirrors it doesn't actually happen as
this closes the two of them drive away
and there's a really cool conversation
right Tony Stark says not to get right
back to work but mysterium what is that
right because Emma Frost had kind of
made this off-handed remark in saying
that metal that your dad was talking
about having found that sounds like
mysterium right when she answers this
she says your father had clearly nosed
on to it but I suspect he never got his
hands on any it's a metal that's only
available to be mined by mutants from a
place outside space and time that we
call the white hot room we were using it
as more soft power after the
terraforming of or Rocko why does the
white hot room matter well one the white
hot room exists beyond the far Shore
right the far Shore is kind of like this
realm in Marvel Comics is the very edge
of all space and time it was previously
believed that beyond the far Shore is
where like the one above all resided and
maybe out there somewhere he does but
beyond the far Shore is also the white
hot room that's where the Phoenix Force
operates in Marvel Comics right this
kind of sum total of all life and
psychic energy that has currently does
or will ever exist a source of
astronomical power now the nature of
mysterium as we've seen from The Sword
comics and Marvel in recent years and so
on it's not like this all-encompassing
all indestructible metal but it is
comparable to secondary adamantium that
was presented to us in the sword Comics
what does that mean it's not as durable
as Wolverine's adamantium skeleton but
it's pretty freaking close in effect
Iron Man is getting ready to build an
adamantium Iron Man suit and that is
going to be dope with that being said
guys if you need to get caught up on
fall of X make sure you guys click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace